trois cent mille personnes qui ont été
évacuées c'est énorme
il faut comprendre que les autorités aux
philippines ont appris à la suite
passage de yann l'an dernier il ya un
plan d'urgence qui a été mis sur pied et
d'ailleurs c'était la première fois que
le conte l'expérimenté donc ce qu'on a
fait à ses fins qu on n 28 pratiquement
toutes les personnes qui habitaient dans
des bidonvilles vous savez santé maisons
de fortune sur les comptes en bordure
des villes qui ne peuvent pas résister à
de forts vents et d'ailleurs le titre
aura mason qui a amené avec lui des
bourrasques de francs 60 à 180 km donc
il est évident que cela permit de sauver
des vies mais le défi c'est de trouver
d'abord un gîte à ces personnes et de
les nourrir aussi parce que dans
certains cafés sinistri qui ont
l'impression de revivre encore une fois
un cauchemar qui habite depuis huit mois
depuis le passage de yann encore dans
des tentes dont vraiment des moments
difficiles mais malgré tout les dégâts
ne sont pas trop énorme
en tout cas à comparer à ce qu'avaient
les faits yann on se rappellera que huit
mois alors qu'il y en ait passé au moins
neuf ans plus de finalement et encore
mille personnes qui l'ont dit abu
élégant est devenu à 2 milliards de
dollars
alors c'est un typhon qui se déplace
maintenant vers le vietnam et la chine
la chine qui est déjà aux prises avec
d'importantes inondations alors ça va
s'ajouter cette situation déjà difficile
exactement sauf que l'innovation ne se
trouve pas sur la côte mais au centre de
la chine a ensuite dans la ville
historique de fans gamme vous allez voir
les images qui sont vraiment
impressionnantes
dans cette région la passe à dix jours
le conte à des pluies diluviennes
la rivière qui normalement est
impeccable elle a peint en ce moment
cinquante mille personnes qui ont été
évacuées mais heureusement dans cette
région là on ne déplore aucun blessé
grave
merci beaucoup il vend côté au revoir